[Music]
good evening I'm Glen urban Dean of the
MIT Sloan School and it's my pleasure to
welcome you to this inaugural session of
the MIT Sloan School Oxford University
Distinguished Lecture series this is a
real partnership between the Oxford
University Press and the Sloan School
we're trying to bring distinguished
academic speakers here to campus and
produce high-impact books based on their
lectures I think our goal here is to
really bring leading-edge thinking about
the future of business in front of you
in terms of in-person things in this
series and then to our audience in in
written form before I introduce Bob so I
would like to let Ed Barrie who's the
president of Oxford University Press in
the US have a chance to say just a
couple words about the purposes and
history of this series and then I will
finish with the introduction
thank you very much Glenn and thank all
of you for attending this inaugural
lecture in this absolutely beautiful
auditorium we of course hope that the
lectures jointly sponsored by Oxford and
Sloan will become a major forum
addressing fundamental issues in the
business world now I have two reasons
for being delighted to be here tonight
the first one's professional and the
second one is personal as president of
Oxford University Press we committed
ourselves about 10 years ago to trying
to publish the very best advanced level
business books in the United States and
I think we're really making some good
strides partly because so many of our
authors are being drawn from the Sloan
School so therefore on the professional
side I'm really delighted that that
we're formalizing this relationship
between Sloan and Oxford University
Press and that we're embarking upon this
very exciting venture I should say
related to that is another reason that
we're a little bit proud it was about
500 years ago that Oxford University
Press published its first book taking
advantage of the invention of the
printing press and taking advantage of
technology so it seems particularly
appropriate that the press would join
with a university whose very name
includes the work word technology and
particularly nice to see us doing this
at a time when technology is becoming
increasingly important in the world on a
personal level I've got a special reason
for being happy
it was probably 25 years ago before my
hair turned white
that I was president of the Free Press
and I was I was publishing with a great
deal of pride the most distinguished
sociologists in the United States Robert
K Merton now some time after that not
quite 25 years ago a little less than
that going back from here we were
chasing after a younger Robert Merton
Robert see Merton trying to convince him
that he should sign a book with the Free
Press at that time well he didn't get
time to do that book for the Free Press
but now we have captured him with the
lecture and a book that will follow
however the actual introduction here is
going to be by Glenn who has known the
Sun almost as long as I have known the
father then we are indeed fortunate to
have Professor Bob Merton here to give
this inaugural address Bob and I do go
back a long way I came here at MIT in
1966 and he was starting his PhD about
the same time and finished the PhD with
Paul Samuelson in 1970 and then Bob was
on our faculty here at the Sloan School
for 18 years during that time he and
Myron Scholes and Fischer black invented
option theory and then Bob went on
singularly himself to revolutionize the
field with continuous-time modeling and
finance
Bob's now teaching at Harvard we think
of that as a short-term loan there but
as well this year he's on leave at a
very successful firm that he co-founded
called long term capital and those of
you who know the market know how hot
that company is so Bob's one of these
unique individuals who can contribute on
the academic level as well as that
create an extremely successful business
so it's a real pleasure to welcome Bob
to give this first lecture called the
management of financial institutions
into the 21st century and please do mark
your calendars because he'll give two
more April 24th and May first which will
complete the trilogy so Bob welcome
well thank you Glenn and and thank you
for coming and inviting me I'm certainly
deeply honored to be here for the
inaugural of the Oxford University MIT
Sloan lecture in business and all the
more so is Glenn has told you because I
had the great good fortune to spend
nearly two decades here at MIT with a
wonderful set of colleagues classmates
earlier and then colleagues on the
faculty my overall topic for the three
lectures is the management of financial
service firms into the 21st century for
any business it is of course primal to
establish what purpose it will serve
before analyzing its organizational
structure and management design and so
tonight I explore the range of
innovative financial products and
services that are likely to be offered
to households business firms
corporations and governments and the
influence that these new financial
products may have on the economic
activities of those customers of the
financial institutions external customer
demands thus identified I will in the
second neck lecture next week look
internally into the financial
institution to focus on risk management
as the central managerial component
necessary in a first-rate high-quality
production process for financial
products and services of the future in
the third lecture I try my hand at
examining the complexities of long term
strategic management of the financial
institution in an environment rapidly
changing of rapidly changing
geopolitical regulatory and
institutional boundaries and driven by
technological and financial innovation
in doing so
I will offer a functional perspective as
a means for analyzing the dynamics of
institutional change within the
financial system and thereby provide a
conceptual framework for strategic
analysis of the individual financial
firm as we move through the lectures you
will undoubtedly detect a managerial
focus on how things should work instead
of on how things may not work I am not
inherently an optimist I do however
believe that in the study of the
financial system as in the study of the
human body physiology precedes pathology
i thus reserve four portions of my last
lecture the discussion of management and
financial pathology I do so in the last
lecture
not because pathology is uninteresting
but precisely because it is too
interesting the manifest objective of
these lectures is to analyze the
management of financial institutions
nevertheless I harbor the hope that some
will see a more latent one namely to
offer the financial service industry as
a possible strategic research site that
may cast some light on the management
issues of other globally competitive
industries which operate on a large
scale and experience rapid and
continuing innovation i underscore at
the outset that the forecasts expressed
here are not necessarily uniformly
shared among my colleague financial
economists as we all know too well the
historical standard errors in
forecasting of the economic future are
notoriously large thus the practitioner
and researcher alike should therefore
approach the ones given here tentatively
and assess their limitations carefully
in any application
new financial products and market
designs improve computer
telecommunications technologies and
advances in a theory of finance during
the past quarter-century have led to
dramatic and rapid changes in the
structure of global financial markets
and institutions the scientific
breakthroughs in financial modeling in
this same period some made right here at
Sloan most notably Fischer black and
Myron Scholes the black Scholes model
these financial model modeling
breakthroughs both shaped and were
shaped by the extraordinary flow of
financial innovation which coincided
with those changes now to put this in
perspective I remind you that the fall
of brentd woods leading to floating
exchange rates the development of the
National mortgage market in the United
States the first oil shock and the
creation of the first listed options
exchange accompanied publication of the
famous black Scholes option pricing
model in 1973 ERISA and the subsequent
development of the US pension fund
industry as well as the first money fund
with check-writing
both occurred in 1974 now accounts began
in 1976 and 25 years ago total assets at
all youths u.s. mutual funds were 48
billion dollars today they are more than
50 times larger with one complex alone
fidelity holding more than are managing
more than four hundred billion dollars
in assets in this same period average
daily trading volume on the New York
Stock Exchange grew from 12 million to
nearly 300 million now the cumulative
impact has significantly affected all of
us as users producers or overseers of
the financial system innovation is a
central force driving the financial
system towards greater economic
efficiency and considerable economic
benefit has accrued from the changes of
the past 25 years
moreover there has been vast
improvements in our understanding of how
to use the new financial technologies to
manage risk despite all of this we find
today an intense concern among managers
regulators politicians the press and the
public over the new activities and risks
of financial institutions relative to
their traditional risks and activities
such as commercial real estate loans or
LDC debt now why why this concern
despite the gains and benefits well one
conjecture about the sources of this
collective anxiety on the risks of the
new activities holds that their
implementation has required major
changes in the basic institutional
hierarchy and in the infrastructure to
support it as a consequence the
knowledge base required to manage and
oversee financial institutions differs
considerably from the traditional
training and experience of many
financial managers as well as governor
governmental regulators changes of this
sort are threatening it is difficult to
deal with change that is exogenous with
respect to our traditional knowledge
base and framework and therefore comes
to seem beyond our control less
understanding of the new environment can
create a sense of greater risk even when
the objective level of risk in the
system is unchanged or actually reduced
that knowledge gap may widen since the
current pace of financial innovation is
anticipated to continue and even
accelerate into the next decade managing
this knowledge gap offers considerable
challenge to institutions but it also
offers considerable opportunities to
schools of management such as MIT
now the same points about managers and
overseers can be made about households
the ultimate consumer consumers of
financial services one major
institutional change over the last 15
years or so has been the disaggregation
of financial services especially at the
retail level another has been
deregulation combined by necessity with
a reduction in government guarantees of
financial performance these changes cast
significantly more individual
responsibility for risk bearing directly
on to the household in the United States
for example the fully government
guaranteed bank deposit with an interest
rate set by regulation which was once
virtually the only form of liquid
short-term asset holding of households
now shares significant space with a
variety of substitutes such as money
funds which are not guaranteed with
respect to payment interest rate or
liquidity where once social security and
defined benefit corporate pension plans
assured households of a no thought
provision for retirement there is now a
major shift toward defined contribution
pension plans in which the amounts of
ill but retirement depend exclusively on
the returns earned on invested funds
during the work years now in all of this
the household now bears the
responsibility for the allocation of the
funds among investment alternatives even
residential mortgages which had almost
always set at a fixed rate in the US
have now shifted towards variable rates
which subject the household to direct
interest rate risk exposure thus like
financial managers and regulators
households are now being called upon to
make important financial decisions
involving risk that they have not had to
make in the past and may
not be trained to make in the present
and in this sense the evolving structure
of the financial system has a
dysfunctional aspect the successful
financial institutions in the impending
future will be those that can address
this dysfunctional aspect while still
fully exploiting the functional benefits
of new financial technology to help
forecast managerial demands including
the type of research and training needed
to run financial institutions as we
enter the next century I turn now to the
future product and service demands of
the business and consider to begin with
the household sector of customers now as
I've noted to you the retail investors
in the most developed financial systems
the United States particular have
experienced a secular train of trend of
disaggregation and financial services
there are those who see this trend
continuing and furthermore that the
existing products such as mutual funds
will be transported into technologically
less developed systems well perhaps that
is what will be the case but I also I
believe that the trend will reverse back
towards more aggregated products if
you'll permit me a bit of an analogy is
the idea of consumers when I was growing
up I had in my living room a hi-fi set
that was in a box to listen to music had
the record player the amplifier
everything in a box we bought a box very
handsome box by the way and we listened
to music and then evolved the components
explosion and you have high five shops
where you had amplifiers preamplifiers
woofers subwoofers all these things all
over the shelves and it was wonderful
I'm not suggesting that this was a
mistake but it also had his
dysfunctional aspect which meant that
most of us who are either not trained
nor particularly interested in building
systems would walk in and say what we
would like to have in fact is not the
component parts not the woofer and the
tweeters or whatever we
I have something that delivers to us the
music product at a price that we could
afford in the environment that we're in
now what happened what has happened
we've seen a trend back to the box of
course it's not the same box that I grew
up with it's a much better one that's
the result of technology but
nevertheless it's a box perhaps the best
known and four is the so called now I
guess media room where the whole room is
made of box but the idea is that at the
consumer level to bring back and move
toward the direction of an aggregated
finished products rather than leave the
consumer with thousands and thousands of
mutual funds untold other individual
financial products and ask the consumer
that was ill-prepared to do so either by
training or desire and certainly is not
the unit that is best served by bearing
what we call basis risk or shortfall
risk by asking them to assemble these in
some way that approach anything optimal
certainly doesn't seem the most likely
event as how things should work so in
thinking about the new financial
products they will be aggregated they
should be easy to understand the case
would be for example someone who is
looking who had a two-year-old child and
was concerned about tuition for that
child going to perhaps MIT or Harvard
but maybe some other university here in
the United States in 16 years under most
cases I know there are exceptions but in
most cases how is that plan achieved you
go to a financial planner they say put
money in a Growth Fund or some mix of
growth funds and if you put enough in in
16 years you should have enough to pay
for tuition and if you look at
historical returns you can even make an
estimate of how much you have to put in
in order to meet tuition but what
happens if the ex-post performance of
those collection
fun's over the subsequent 16 years does
not match expectations in fact deviates
considerably from it well if it turns
out they earn a lot more than is needed
for tuition you might say well that's
great except of course there could be
some degree of regret because that says
that the parent didn't the parents
didn't have to put so much away and they
could have consumed it earlier something
that cannot be reversed now can't go
back in time as far as I know but
there's of course the other side there's
a shortfall who bears that risk under
the decentralized disaggregated products
risk the advisory type business in this
area the individual household does I
would think that the move should be
toward aggregation towards a product
that simply says you put so much in your
child's tuition is paid for and let the
professionals let the institutions are
supposed to provide these services
undertake the risk bearing the analysis
and what we might call the basis of
shortfall risk now an organizing theme
for thinking about these consumer
products in the future
I think can be found in MIT zones Franco
Modigliani x' work on the lifecycle
those of you had the good fortune to
still be and take his class no well what
I talk about from the master and so I
wouldn't pretend even talked about the
lifecycle here you but I will say that I
find it point that it's common to every
time and place different countries
different period of time the lifecycle
feature is a common is a common theme
and thus highly transportable and thus
highly usable in a global environment
with rapidly changing technology as a
way of framing the kinds of products
that we would like to design an offer
now at this point in time probably the
most important in terms of impact in the
next year's
we'll be the retirement phase of the
lifecycle I need hardly mention here
that baby boomers but also Germany Japan
and quite another the other more
developed economies in which we see an
incredible you know a very strong sort
of graying of the population and a need
to address the pop the retirement
segment more effectively just to give
you some numbers in Germany in 1990
twenty percent of the population were
age sixty and over by 2020 it's forecast
that that percentage will be thirty
percent and by 2030 thirty five percent
now we all know how accurate demographic
forecasts are so forth but even if
they're off by quite a bit that's an
extraordinary change for that country
and in in any event if it does reach
thirty five percent it's a good bet that
that's going to be close to half the
voting population or something that akin
to that maybe maybe no I guess be larger
smaller but a very substantial amount of
the voting population I mention this
because if you look at Germany and I'm
not a German expert but you see that
they have sixty percent marginal tax
rates they do not have any funding of
either social security or corporate
pension plans and in fact the tax
incentives are against funding for
corporate pension plans there is mutual
guarantees across the corporations of
pensions but as I understand it those
corporations could choose to opt out of
the system by developing what we would
call here in the States the equivalent
of defined contribution plans for all of
those who are students of adverse
selection and moral hazard
what do you think that suggests as to
who will win the ones to opt out of that
system and who will stay if they still
have the choice there's a historical
unacceptability of inflation and you add
to that that strains of EMU leadership
if the MU comes to be and the question
although it's claimed that they have
covered the costs of bringing in the
East whether they've included in
those costs all the retirement and
pension benefits as extended the
parallel numbers for the u.s. 16.6%
elected to mention if you know
retirement age standard retirement age
in Germany is 60 so that cutoff is by
the way not a not an irrelevant one in
terms of percentages in the United
States sixteen six to twenty eight
percent in the period in Japan seventeen
percent to thirty three percent now some
see in this more than just a crisis they
see disaster well perhaps one can also
see in that a challenge and opportunity
for financial services firms financial
institutions to do it their part to help
meet this challenge of the graying of
the population meet these part of the
lifecycle retirement worldwide and
profit by it and not only is the aging
making those opportunities but as I'm
sure you're all aware there is at the
periods of a trend away from the
government component of providing for
retirement what we would broadly call
Social Security towards privatization so
you have two events going on both the
size of the population that it's going
to need retirement services globally or
I shouldn't say globally in the in the
more developed Congress this is not true
in Latin America and in other parts but
in certainly in the countries I
mentioned and in most of Europe so you
have the aging but you also have fact
that privatization is taking place of
this of the retirement provisions and
with that you'll have an even greater
chunk being transferred directly to
financial services firms to deliver if
existing institutions such as insurance
companies and banks cannot or do not
change so as to address this challenge I
believe other new types of institutions
will arise that will
but further discussion of the character
of those institutions and the dynamics
of institutional change our topics for
my third lecture so I will move on from
this one now all of this about the
household products and services creates
a kind of paradox if the forecast is for
consumer products to become more user
friendly simpler to understand what to
do what they do and more customized and
tailored to meet individual profiles
then paradoxically making the product
simple creates considerably more
complexity for the producer of those
products and thus financial engineering
creativity and the technological base to
implement that creativity with
reliability and at low cost will be a
key competitive element in financial
services
let me give any simple example of what
I'm trying to now consider again in the
retirement phase a life annuity by that
as you receive payments for the rest of
your life after retirement
so you're assured of receiving the
funding for as long as you're alive but
instead of a standard annuity at least
standard in the United States which pays
a fixed dollar amount each period for
the rest of your life imagine that
annuity is indexed but not indexed
solely for inflation thereby trying to
provide a protection against inflation
but nothing else but also indexed
against the standard of living so that
if the standard of living in the
environment in which you reside
increases the annuity payments increase
in such a way that in principle you
could not only enjoy the standard of
living that you had but in fact keep up
in a relative sense to those around you
now I'm not saying that's the annuity
that everyone would pick but it seemed
to me like it sounds like a
fairly simple a sensible one for a lot
of people allowing you to maintain the
standard that you hadn't during that
life you were working and allowing you
to keep up with changes in a standard
living and I underscore to you that's
much more important particularly for
many of the people the group here
because I suspect you will be working
longer than then some anticipate now but
you'll also be living in retirement much
longer and so that during your period
after retirement the exposure to
significant standard of living changes
is not remain be non-trivial and and
more important but let's stick with that
product simply pretty simple to to
describe just a user what does it take
to create that problem well relative to
the fixed money rate annuity which
basically with a little mortality risk
any insurance company can create using
available readily available fixed
incomes instruments it's not quite that
simple but close to it this other
product will require substantial
engineering and innovation and
technology in order to deal with the
basis risks in the issuing institution
associated not only with inflation but
with changes in the standard of living
complexity in the production process
with the ends being simplicity for the
customer will require elaborate and
highly quantitative risk management
systems within the institution that's
the topic of next week lecture so let me
move to the next class of customers to
institutions the corporate customer and
on the managing of risk outside
financial institutions now we know that
non-financial firms now use derivatives
securities and other contractual
agreements to hedge interest rates
currency and commodity price risks with
improved lower cost technology and
learning curve experience both on the
side of users corporate users and on the
side of financial firms who provide the
advice
the instruments but with this learning
curve experience this practice is likely
to expand eventually this alternative to
equity capital by that I mean hedging as
a control for risk may have a major
influence on corporate structures as
more firms can use this hedging and
therefore freed up to move from publicly
traded equity to privately closely held
equity by that I mean equity is kind of
an all-purpose bucket
it's the cushion for risks that were
unanticipated in the firm all risks
because just a pop it's a cushion
hedging whether it's commodity prices or
interest rates or inflation rates or
whatever temperature degree temperatures
in the state of Minnesota but hedging
those are hedging the opposite of equity
in this dimension in a sense they're
very specialized
they're targeted risk management and so
it takes quite different skill and a
quite different set of tools to
implement that form of managing risk
than the equity alternative but with
those skills and the lower cost
provision for hedging then some of the
alternative the benefits of moving from
large blocks of publicly held equity to
closely held corporations closely held
controlled businesses where the equity
is closely held is made more feasible so
that's an example of an influence on
structure outside financial institutions
the other major area for the
applications are for financial
innovation products in the future for
corporate customers is in strategic
management of the firm favorite example
of mine and some of you I recognize the
orders heard it many times but if it's a
good example it's hard to not give it
again and some of you at least may not
have heard it the 1i hack is that no
should one of the ones I like is that of
the sin
Fedak refinery where you imagine a firm
with oil fields you can do this with gas
of course well let's keep it with oil
fields and also the distribution system
let's say for heating oil and gasoline
but missing the centerpiece the refining
component to transforms the crude into
finished products to be distributed and
let's suppose that this firm does a
strategic analysis and decides based on
the risks of the need to coordinate that
it's decided to have vertical
integration they ought to introduce the
refining component the middle piece now
in the past that would have meant either
buying a refinery existing one or
building one and that is indeed one
possible solution and may even be the
best solution in some cases but now
there is an alternative and the
alternative is to enter into financial
contracts in which for example you
deliver crude oil in quantities and
places at times and in return receive
perhaps with a delay not alone like that
of physical production see even a delay
some mix of gasoline heating oil and so
forth in return in a financial contract
and you can jazz it up to have it be an
option type contract so at the time of
the delivery of the crude you have the
choice as to what mix of refined
products you'll receive just as you
would with a refinery with multiple
outputs from the input functionally
you're bringing in crude and you're
getting back refined products so in that
sense you've achieved
the economic purpose of integration of
the process
but in many cases that will be a far
superior solution so the actual
acquisition of the physical refinery and
we could go into issues of EPA during
the United States refineries are not
some of those pleasant things to have
around and there's a tendency to have
them elsewhere
there's the expertise of going to
environments in countries to areas run
these refineries where you have no
expertise as a institution or firm and
so forth there's also a flexibility of
supply such a refinery is typically in
one place that you can have subdivision
of refining capability now the
counterparty to this contract with this
firm could be a special deterrent firm
in refining specialize in that but it
also could be a financial firm which is
in itself intermediating or laying it
off with a host of other institutions
perhaps in some cases just simply using
the standard futures markets as a form
of hedging the contractual agreement now
if I could give you a second example one
that is unfolding at this very time that
involves the production and distribution
of electric power as documented in a
delightful and informative case study by
my colleague at HBS Peter Tufano the
Tennessee Valley Authority TVA in
December of 1994 began a process of
accepting bids to have qualified
producers and perhaps some financial
firms bid to sell to TVA long-dated call
options to buy power at a pre-specified
price and to buy put options from TVA
giving them the counterparty the right
to sell TVA power at a fixed price TVA
as I remind some of you if you don't
know produces and transmits power
through a grid it was developed in the
30s as a power generating
well the TVA projects okay the scale of
the bids was the power output equivalent
of two to two-and-a-half nuclear power
plants which you know being an MIT I
have to be very careful because I'm sure
there are those who will correct me but
what I understand is about the
equivalent of 30 conventional power
plants in terms of output
thus when this process is completed TVA
will have the economic equivalent of
those plants without actually owning or
building them and hence the synthetic
power plant so they will have contracts
which give them the right to get power
from the system from others from the
counterparty these are very long dated
contracts not short term options as you
see typically traded on stocks and so
forth they have also sold puts two
counterparties so those of you are
facile with these things you can see
they've done something like a range
forward contract or a synthetic forward
contract but it's more complex than that
as I understand it because they're not
matched and so forth but the essential
feature is they made a strategic
decision to create robust and available
and low-cost
supply of power by entering in these
contractuals
as a competing alternative to building
the power plants this process went on
through most of 1995 and it makes
feasible as with the refining case the
economic integration of generation of
power transmission and distribution but
without having to have the physical
managerial integration and take
advantage of the division of expertise
that is necessary with actual
integration it's been reported that by
the TVA but with no official connector
but it just came out in the newspaper
after these bids completed that they
have made a decision
the TVA has made a decision not to build
to nuclear
powerplants perhaps that's coincidental
but at least it would make a good story
to suggest that they've used the
financial contract and they've been
engaged in as a substitute and have
found it to be a superior substitute now
to complement these custom-tailored
contracts these are bilateral
arrangements between TVA and their
counterparties they are not publicly
known so unfortunately I don't know what
their particular terms are but to
complement that just about two weeks ago
futures contracts on Electric Power have
begun trading on the New York Mercantile
Exchange and some are predicting that as
as much as one trillion dollars of these
contracts will be trading by the year
2000 and that the further effects on
other businesses that depend critically
on power is likely to be significant I
should also say and there's another set
of cases and so with a little bit
earlier that much the same story applies
to natural gas and indeed there's a
company called Enron that is essentially
turned itself in the way it looks to me
like an investment bank of sorts but
instead of dealing with money it uses
gas as the unit now a major requirement
for the successful application of these
contracting alternatives will be to find
effective organizational structures for
ensuring contract performance both for
contracts issued to households and for
contracts issued to corporations and
this will require global clarification
and revisions of the treatment of such
contractual agreements in bankruptcy
simply put if we're going to have these
contracts especially custom contracts
used with customers used with
corporations and used effectively it
must be that what's promised is on the
whole delivered and it must be clear and
I make an aside on that that default on
these customer contracts has
significantly greater efficiency losses
then defaults on
of the same institution to investors the
reason being is investors expect that
their returns from investing in a
company whether its debt or equity will
be influenced by the future of fortunes
of that company so that's part of the
process of being an investor but whether
you are a customer whether corporate
customer or household customer you do
not want the payments on your contracts
to be contingent on the performance of
the issuing institution the refining
company the company that wants refining
wants to get the crude in give the crude
in and get back to refined products and
it doesn't want to have it getting those
conditional which institution actually
issued the contract that's not part of
the state contingency this desire and so
there's enormous efficiency gains and
growth gains by using that the need for
assurances on contracts performance is
likely to stimulate further development
of financial guarantee business for
financial institutions and such
institutional so we'll have to improve
further the efficiency of collateral
management as assurance for performance
now we move to the third category of
customer the government first things
that are needed by the government in
this dimension will be education and
training for oversight you imagine what
this is like for regulators for
[Music]
supervisors to look at all this
complexity and sometimes oversee it and
clearly need to understand it one of the
things we may see happening is that the
solution is that it gets farmed out that
instead of government or government
agencies coming in and doing all the
checking evaluation there will be
external firms specialized firms not on
like those of public accounting firms
that we are all familiar with that will
be creative perhaps
risk accounting or some other better
type of term but specialized firms that
will go in and do evaluations of the
appropriate institutions to see and they
indeed whether they are complying with
the relevant standards and that may be a
far more efficient and effective way to
undertake this but we'll see in the
direction however it's not just merely
as the outside overseer but just the
activities of government itself in the
financial sector that will make use of
this technology monetary policy as we
all know much of the at least
theoretical effect of this theoretical
reasons for effectiveness of monetary
policies turn on frictions you need some
kinds of costs or frictions in the
financial system in order to have the
monetary policy bite now we have seen an
extraordinary reduction in costs in the
financial transactions principally
through derivatives but also in even the
more traditional areas the ability to
contract and contract at low cost and
the existence of the large number of
markets have all combined together with
again technology to reduce costs
dramatically so it's not at all clear
that those approaches to implementing
monetary policies that were entirely
effective if they work in a relatively
high friction environment will also be
effective in a low friction environment
those of you know Mount Washington up
here you know you can drive up there in
the summer in a car with ordinary tires
that's one friction level try it again
in the winter you might find it's a
quite different one and so what's the
successful technology and high friction
may not be in the lower third area
fiscal policy more and more countries
have to deal with the reality that
they're depending on capital as their
flows both back and forward with global
investors and so
specialized types of taxes such as
withholding taxes on debt and so forth
perhaps designed to generate revenues
are in fact just introducing largely
frictions and cost hi me dear Motty and
tournelle Rockefeller I don't know how
many people in here know the name
Rockefeller it's not spelled the
Rockefellers in finance but perhaps in
mathematics convex analysis optimization
very eminent mathematician team together
and wrote a little book a little
monograph called the mathematics of debt
instruments taxation and this was
apparently written in collaboration with
some lawyers who preferred to remain
unnamed and on credit and the title of
the book was mathematics of debt
instruments taxation in the United
States and basically what they did is to
try to take the entire tax code in the
United States as a bar on debt the
taxation of debt and as they put it the
first seventy pages is redefining a lot
of terms that don't make a you know they
don't have a lot of consistency to them
but the last twelve or so have nothing
but mathematical equations that purport
to fully represent that whole debt
structure with all the inequalities who
now for my point here it doesn't matter
whether they fully effectively done it I
think they probably have done a pretty
decent job and but there's no doubt that
somebody with what we have to do a
better job if they haven't done a good
enough job and what is the implication
of that tax legislation typically based
on the case method dealing with specific
contracts that debt contracts that are
familiar are formulated in such a way
that they did not contemplate very
different kinds of contracts and very
different all of them under the heading
of debt and as a result their own down
will be will be unintended consequences
of that tax structure as the result of
if you like the exploitation of using
this mathematical structure that fully
captures it
and then applying optimization
techniques which effectively minimize
the tax costs or that's had maximize tax
benefits but this same technology could
be used by the government to design more
functionally consistent and effective
tax rules and thus those who are going
to be engaged in fiscal policy will have
to come facile with these elements of
analysis and security design the last
element in government stabilization of
currency and interest rates central
bankers are now discussing using
derivative markets as more efficient
than the cash market for implementing
both on interest rates and currencies
stabilization policies and indeed I
wouldn't be surprised to see them do it
in the future in a major way now I'm
looking at the time I don't remember
when I started but I can see we're
getting there
and it's getting a little warm so I'd
like to however to point out one major
last thought as it deals with this so of
course this is not to say that financial
technology and the institutions that
provide this technology can provide a
solution for all the world's economic
ills
I've been sounding here like a
cheerleader to some degree like this is
a solution in general we know they
involve trade-offs these example talking
about retirees retirees during the
accumulation period certainly our
providers of capital they will better be
able to take care of themselves in
retirement if they earn high returns on
that capital so hence we'd like high
returns for retirees but that's not the
only policy objective or economic
objective in our societies we also have
interest in more jobs jobs and growth
well the users of that capital
entrepreneurs and business firms will
clearly be able to invest more if the
cost of capital is lower so for that
purpose we'd like to see low required
returns so the users of capital want
lower returns the providers of capital
with high returns and from a public
policy point of view I think both of
this could if not to sympathize
empathize with both parties
so these at this level are an apparent
conflict and therefore it must be
resolved as a trade-off but sometimes
both can be improved make both better
off and how is that well we tend to
neglect it in our basic economics
courses you have the providers of
capital let's keep it with the retirees
and we have the users of capital let's
say the entrepreneurs and we just
presume they get brought together in
some frictionless costless fashion but
as we all know it's a very complex
distribution system that allows that
capital to get from providers to users
and in certain environments those costs
could be quite substantial the spread
cost all I mean by that is retirees the
providers get 8% on their investment
entrepreneurs and business firms have to
pay 10% on their investment and the
spread that 2% is the cost of getting
the two together and that service is one
of the things that financial
institutions and financial markets and
the financial system is proposed to form
if we can find ways to reduce that
spread to tighten it up to reduce the
cost of that distribution then it is
indeed possible to have both parties do
better from eight to eight and a half
for example from 10 down to nine and a
half on the other side a 1% spread
and to the extent that financial
technology can be employed to reduce
that spread it could have a large and
profound effect I'll give you one number
for the Republic of Italy if you could
find a way to reduce their interest
costs by one percent 100 basis points
you would give back to the Republic in
the form of reduced costs one and a
quarter percent of the GDP of Italy at
least a measure GDP of Italy that's a
huge number there's a great study out
there to be done I don't know if it has
about a where that one has been done of
the economic benefits of the u.s.
mortgage market just in terms of the
sheer size I'm not going to talk about
that but I throw that out to be thought
of these are very large and very real
savings and efficiency and contribution
that can be achieved if you want to see
a dice case on the cost savings of using
contractual agreements versus the cash
market again another colleague of mine
Andre peril at Harvard Business School
is written at so-called B ei case in
which he shows that particularly for
foreign investors whether US and other
countries or other countries in the US
or why do we even have to talk about the
u.s. one country to the other where
those costs can be quite traumatic by
using the cash market but by
implementation of contractual agreements
such as swaps and other alternative
forms of getting the same exposure cost
can be reduced even for institutions as
much as a hundred and fifty to two
hundred basis points now let me say one
other example of that
and that is the idea of creating
liquidity for emerging markets and that
liquidity could be created by
effectively having those who entities
who don't need liquidity such as pension
funds buy shares in emerging market
stock markets which are known to have
very large spreads and put them in a box
buy them once with the idea of never
selling them
put them in a box we'll call it a
depository box okay and then create a
derivative market whether it's a futures
market or some other form which trades
in the index for that emerging country
stock market in which the natural quote
short side that who's willing to issue
the contract is this pension fund which
is fully hedged with the cash securities
in the depository the counterparty on
the other side are all the investors who
for liquidity or other needs could not
otherwise invest in that emerging market
because of the lack of liquidity in
effect your manufacturing liquidity by
going to entities that don't need it and
intermediating it to entities that do in
the process one would hope to see a
substantial reduction in the spreads by
spreading by spreading risk across a
larger base by opening up the op
possibilities to invest in emerging
countries to investors who cuz otherwise
couldn't because of quiddity constraints
now this form of creating liquidity is
one of the earliest example of financial
engineering and derivatives you may
recall that you know people used to at
least as I understand it I wasn't there
but they used to carry gold around on
the trade route so they found that was
very costly hard to carry ease is steel
in some sense and Mayson them to me I
didn't realize it hard to verify that
really was gold okay so someone got the
idea well why don't we just deposit this
gold which is very costly and expensive
to carry around in a box and we'll issue
claims against it and people carry the
claims around and that was the early
depository banks which by the way worked
very well in Europe and a number of
other places and one could argue
certainly helped trade so one of the
earliest derivatives we're bank
banknotes bank deposits issued against
these goals this is a very old tradition
well I've read run on much much longer
than I have right too
you've been very generous to me I would
just close by saying where to look for
clues to future products I would say
look to finance theory rather than
finance history practice is moving
toward theory as much as theory is
changing to better reflect practice I
hope to exemplify that to you those of
you come back next week when I talk
about the development of arrow-debreu
securities something you all know is
fundamental to understanding the theory
of risk has been since 1953 but of which
all of us who studied it realized was
totally impractical to have in the real
world but indeed arrow-debreu securities
do exist in the real world and their
structure is used as a key element of
the production and risk management of
financial products within sophisticated
institutions so those of you who would
like to come back next week I'll talk
about that thank you very much it's a
great pleasure and thank you all the for
giving this wonderful building it's a
delight it's a treat to be up here thank
you
[Applause]
Jen's anyone may want to have yes sir
you might want to try and spread or
decrease the spread between providers
and consumers of capital if the current
model is such that financial
institutions are kind of making their
living off of that spread and in this
new environment they're gonna be called
upon to increase the pace of innovation
how where are they going to get the
funds to do that that's a fair question
everybody did you like me to repeat the
question did you hear it question is why
would I on the discussion of the
management of financial institutions
introduced the idea of reducing spreads
which would seem to reduce the
profitability of the businesses well
there's no question that that sort of
change in the future as well as it's
been true in the past will invoke large
losses on some financial institutions in
fact they'll put a lot of them
potentially out of business but for
those who can do it efficiently and come
up with a better mousetrap and a better
way to do it I think they can make if
you'll excuse the special and there's a
ton of money okay I wouldn't worry about
their ability to get the resources
necessary to perform those functions
because you have to remember there's a
huge scale that's one thing secondly if
you're good at what you do designing
these things the technology can actually
in certain dimensions make you vastly
much more efficient and third I think
you have to recognize that there are a
range of products the most innovative
most custom-made products at least
initially will have larger markups not
because they're ripping anyone off but
just because they're providing such good
service for the money they also be cases
of you know but that doesn't you know
but but I mean by that as I say that
it's perfectly sensible right and those
can be high margin products you'll have
others that will focus in the high
volume areas it's no any different in
the business but the best answer to you
is that you don't have a choice
you don't do it someone else will okay
this is not a business that's going to
last very long as a worldwide cartel if
it ever did it's just too profitable too
easy with the technology to enter so
another question yes sir
reduce the reliance on equity and
actually shift the pool of companies for
being public to be private
is there any tendency for some
industries to be more sensitive well I
think the type of industry that has if
you look at very large firms like that
size huge in terms of the asset value
and so forth which are privately held I
believe this is that they in this day
and age are typically more commodity
type companies oil and other types of
commodities one hypothesis I don't say
that it's this effect one hypothesis for
that is that even under today's and even
some time ago technology it is
relatively easy to hedge commodity risks
and therefore one can manage a lot of
the risks and a commodity firm therefore
you don't need the large equity cushion
what I was suggesting is as that
technology gets better and costs or
reduce a wider range of types of
industries or businesses may find it to
move in this direction as well we talked
about electric power or I talked about
temperature it's really rather amazing
and temperature by the way for those
even allowed to brew securities it's
pretty much an exogenous thing so we're
very close to it that answer your
question
yes sir well the answer to your question
is ultimately in some sense households
always bear the risk they're the
ultimate consumers of everything in a
sense I mean the firm's and everything
else they're conduits so in that what
we're really talking about is a
redistribution of it what I would say is
not efficient is to households making
large number of highly technical
decisions where they don't have access
to the markets to implement them the
same way that larger units do they don't
have the scale to they don't have the
knowledge base to to to do it I don't
mean to say they don't end up bearing
risk but the kind of risk they bear will
be much more efficient that will be
trade-offs of course but it won't be of
the this kind that you have now in which
it just is it's just not a good match if
you want a quick pass through what I'm
talking about if you go to a narrow de
bruit type world people hold securities
there you would certainly agree that
households are bearing risk but it's
being borne in the most efficient
fashion possible do you see them in
other words you can have state
contingent payoffs in which you bear the
systemic the irreducible risks if you
like a society or societies but that's
not what I'm talking about talking about
the efficient risk bearing and the
efficient transformations in such a way
that it fits what they would they really
want to do
well where were you proposing to
concentrate it well I hadn't really had
in mind a single grand intermediary for
the for the world
I assume that's not what you mean but I
do think that the intermediation
instruction ERISA actually reduces the
kinds of breakdowns you get when you
have things widely dispersed furthermore
what really happens in most cases is
that individual households don't get the
diversification they should so they're
just inefficient risk bearers high-cost
and efficient I don't see why you see
such a difference or one might see
service between that and the difference
of people who buy the automobiles they
drive having to be set to know how to
assemble them I mean it seems to me it
would be nice thing for me to know but
it doesn't seem to me that's to be a Sun
essential thing I should know in order
you know for the betterment of society
but perhaps maybe we talked about this
after yes is there another question ah
yes
a doll which currently is not
in case one PC
okay well the first part of your
question seemed to call for a forecast
I'll beg off that for the following
reason I don't really know an awful lot
about oil or the Canadian dollar
certainly not enough to make that
forecast but I take your point to be why
is it as oil as the commodity is so
important and yet it seems to have a
relatively illiquid market I'll take
your Givens true I don't know there's to
be factual blows right versus the
Canadian dollar which would all due
respect you being Canadian is important
but not absolutely as important I think
in Part II is what would you do with 20
year old contrast and how why is it is
it so costly to do it it seems to me
that if there's really a very strong
need with the ability to do that kind of
transaction I just thought I don't see
any reason other than that they demands
not therefore the price of creating it I
mean that's pretty tight illogical I
guess but I don't see any hanging hair
and barriers moreover I do say the
following thing that you don't see
something in the past it's rather
remarkable once someone does create
whether it's a hundred year bond or
twenty year market in oil if there's a
fundamental demand for it you know in
other words if somebody really wants to
use it it really helps out in some forms
of hedges they often catch on and the
learning card loads it pretty rapidly
we've seen that in a variety of markets
but I don't really have any good reason
to give you why we don't have twenty
year oil liquidity another question yes
sir
well you say one person isn't one person
it's a probably a set of institutions
this is so not the same but similar to
the previous question I I mean I would
have to say that I don't see reason why
I can't be done so therefore I have to
assume that the cost at the moment is
you know has been too high to do it or
no one's organized it but I guess I turn
it around to you and say it seems to me
that it's a way to produce liquidity
where it could be used there are a bunch
of entities out there and maybe US
pension funds and maybe the US pension
funds couldn't do this under current
regulations I don't know what their
limitations were presume that they could
maybe my suggestions do well why don't
you pursue or what else and some of us
pursue going to these pension funds say
look you just don't need this liquidity
here's the way for you to make use of it
essentially rent your liquidity or sell
liquidity prudently I'm not talking
about selling liquidity as a speculation
not that anything wrong with speculation
but I'm simply saying that that you know
you're the natural holder of such an
entity
now if the spreads are large then
presumably there's a profit option you
can find a way to market it and and deal
with and deal with the the costs but I
don't see why you can't do it so I guess
you're looking at somebody who's always
been a bit of a dreamer and I used to
teach my finance to my master's students
as you know learn a theory and that'll
tell you how to do things in the future
this is MIT where you create things
so I guess my response is I don't see
why it won't happen if it hasn't did you
say I mean I mean I don't flip with you
obviously just investigate these more
closely there's some things that may you
know may not may not work but it's just
very hard for me to believe that
ultimately that isn't a good a good way
of organizing that part of dealing with
emerging market equities and maybe the
own countries have problems with out on
you know
I just can't say another question
well again I thank you very much for
having stayed so long
[Applause]